my name is Julia Ferriero Lee and I'm a
developer advocate with the Google cloud
platform today I have the privilege to
introduce Ashley Gavin who is a
curriculum consultant to schools
nonprofits and companies with an intense
desire to teach young people computer
science hi thanks yeah so during CS ed
week we got to hear a little bit about
the girls who code mission as well as
some of the long-term goals of the
organization so what what drew you to
girls who code um it's actually kind of
a funny story I left my work at MIT
Lincoln Laboratory without a job knowing
that I wanted to move back to New York
write a musical um so really completely
tangential but I got a call from a
friend saying there was this
organization that was teaching young
women out of code and they lost their
robotics instructor and when I was at
Bryn Mawr they offered a course teaching
computer science using personal robots
so I thought oh this is a really good
match and I happen to have ten robots in
my closet as I always do and I said I
can be there next week and so I went in
and learned a little more about the
organization and then never left that's
awesome was the having the 10 robots in
your closet a prerequisite no no but
it's just something that I always have
I'm more robots than any one person and
especially in the closet yeah what kind
of robots are they so they're called
sprinkler robots you can there the robot
itself is made by a company called
parallax you can actually buy them
online and they have a little chip
developed by Bryn Mawr College and
Georgia Tech specifically to run you
know certain api's and such for
educating kids in science that's
fantastic
so curriculum developer that's not a
really a career that you hear about very
often within technology definitely
wasn't one that I had ever heard about
when I graduated with my ICS degree
so tell us a little bit about what what
you do with in girls who code yeah so
when I first started teaching it girls
who code the role of break Elam
developer was not something that I had
heard about either um it sort of formed
itself most my responsibilities very on
a day to day basis
some days I'm helping teachers with
their instruction in the classroom other
days I'm training teachers on how to
give instruction other days I'm writing
code to develop libraries for making
computer science education easier I'm
assessing other people's libraries and
other days I'm just writing a ton of
assignments thinking of creative ways to
get people interested in computer
science through things like art and
music and robotics Act development
things of that nature so it's all over
the place that's working with people
it's working alone it's really fun it
sounds like the perfect combination for
someone whose interests vary quite a bit
as well yeah I think yeah so that sounds
that's awesome
for those who might be interested in
pursuing a similar path can you tell us
a bit about your background and how you
got to where you are today yeah so I
started as a typical computer science
major I knew I wanted to major in
computer science I was lucky enough to
be exposed to computer science in high
school I'm fortunate enough that an
advisor talked to me about it I had
never really thought of teaching as a
career but while I was in college I
loved being a teaching assistant it was
like my favorite thing I worked on a
fellowship where I actually worked with
Bryn Mawr professors on that scribbler
project that I described and when I got
into my later years of college I started
teaching middle schoolers and I found
that all of my extracurricular
activities were centered around teaching
or advertising computer science which
probably should have been a sure sign
that I should do that uh but when I
graduated I went to MIT which was
phenomenal and a great experience but I
found myself yearning to be doing more
interaction with people and to be
helping more in a people in a more
direct way mom and
so that's when I found out about girls
code it kind of dawned on me like oh
maybe you should try doing this for a
living you really like it and I think
it's something that not a lot of
computer science majors consider while
they're in college definitely not it's
it's not a career that I had ever heard
about and it it sounds almost kind of
similar to what what I do in developer
relations as well helping people learn
new technologies so what kind of what
kind of role did science and math play
in your early life do you think that you
were uniquely situated to go into
computer science once you're exposed um
in some ways yes and in some ways
absolutely not
people thought I probably would have
been a train wreck so I'll start with
the yes I played tons of video games as
a kid which is sometimes a telltale sign
that that you might enjoy making a video
game or making technology I was kind of
kid that built websites for fun I loved
Photoshop but simultaneously at the same
time I was flunking biology and getting
fees and math I begged to get out of
math actually but I wasn't allowed to
take computer science at first because
of my poor math grades oh wow yeah yeah
and so I think a lot of people would
have said you know maybe she could be a
graphic designer or web designer but I
don't think a lot of people would have
said that I'd be a good computer
scientist and so finally when my advisor
in high school took over he took over
the computer science department and
opened it up to more kinds of students I
was lucky enough to try it and magically
I was very good at it
and my other grades improved too all the
typical signs of what a student is
excelling you know it's sort of excel
across the board um and I just never
stopped that that's that's an amazing
story what would you say to other young
adults who maybe think that math isn't
really their strong suit but the the
idea behind creation and making that you
oftentimes see in computer science and
technology still appeals to them what
how would you how would you guide to
them
yeah I think I mean there's first of all
the initial fear of feeling like you are
not one of those people or it's not for
you and I would say if you're the kind
of person who enjoyed any art form
creation with your hands with words with
performance I would say at least
consider it and look at it from the
perspective of building a world what
kind of world do you want to build is it
a video game world is it an app world
and that can make it a lot more
appealing and at girls who code we start
our first week entirely building video
games so to keep kids engaged and they
they come out pretty complicated and
pretty fun um as far as directly
actually going out and learning computer
science I think you have to get a little
creative in where you look for resources
because it can be taught a little dry
dry leaf um and I think that's why
people get turned off because they're
not doing a full week-long of video
games since their first assignment so I
actually would recommend looking for a
game development course or an app
development courses and those are
probably a good place to start rather
than straight up computer science I
think it might be more engaging way to
learn gotcha and you actually had the
the benefit of working with robots in
some of the intro classes for computer
science as well would you recommend that
approach to learning computer science
principles absolutely yeah in fact if
you're willing to go out and get one of
these robots or download the software
that we provide links at the end of this
is that a we can we can put them in the
comments okay yeah well put some in the
comments I have some links to open
source materials that you can teach
yourself Python while using either a
real or simulated robot can I recommend
a real robot but not everyone has a few
hundred bucks to shell out for a robot
so or you borrow one of my ten that's
not an offer but we'll provide links I
guess yeah definitely definitely so
let's dive into a little bit of the
girls who code aspect of of your role
here what makes the curriculum of girls
who code different than a traditional CS
education you touched a little bit on
this yeah
there are two ways to look at it there's
the actual content that we teach and
then there's the process by which we
deliver that content in terms of the
actual content that we teach it's very
similar to like the first two semester
of college level computer science and
who said everything is done through a
layout another layer and each week that
layer changes so the first week the
layer is video games the second week
Valera's robotics the third weeks glare
is art like graphics like Pixar for
example sort of thing or other you know
3d animation graphics um and because we
have a different layer every week it's
not just appealing a young women it's
appealing to anyone who has an interest
in any of those layers so if you're the
kind of person that's interested in
medicine or mobile applications you can
find how computer science can be
interesting to you a lot of young women
want to help people so a lot of these
layers as I'm calling them have to do
with helping helping you know people
from medicine or through a sort of
social justice
um and that that makes it very rural
friendlier I just think human friendly
um
I think without that layer it can get
dry and and it's important to have that
on the other side you I think a lot of
computer science education right now is
sort of like the way we learned math
like 50 years ago
it's very wrote it and it's more about
syntax and and language whereas a
grocery code is very project based on
it's very exploratory we don't really
have a set curriculum in terms of today
you're gonna learn about operators or
today you're gonna learn about boolean
s-- we kind of find those topics through
our projects and the projects are
designed to find those topics but the
girls will encounter them on their own
and actually look things up and learn
about them based on their own initiative
which makes it a lot more fun you go out
to learn something because need it to
make that video game work it's a lot
more interesting than learning operators
for the sake of learning operators so
it's exploratory and experimental and
project-based the layers definitely
contextualize the lessons
so that that's fantastic have any
particular layers been especially
successful amongst amongst young women
yeah we do uh I mean this might not come
as a surprise but the mobile athlete is
intensely popular everyone wants to make
a mobile app and some of these apps are
really really impressive and it sort of
brings out their own interests we had
some girls make a mobile application so
that if you don't have a dollar but you
encounter someone on the street a
homeless individual it automatically
pulls up the you actually using the
Google Maps API it automatically pulls
up the closest student kitchens and the
closest homeless shelters and provides
directions because a lot of times
homeless individuals say they'd like to
frequent those locations but they don't
know where they are
they don't have access to technology so
this service does like a little reminder
um that the that the user can can show
this person and kind of has other
information so a really really popular
mobile apps okay so you have a you
obviously have a really interesting role
in technology helping to inspire others
to follow STEM careers
have there been any specific moments
where you thought I can't believe that I
get to do this in my day job
yeah so one comes to mind and I like
just get a little like giggling about it
because it was just so cool um well to
now but the first one was we recently
had an article in The New York Times
mention us something that people noticed
was that there's pretty good gender
equality in biology and forensic
sciences and we noticed that all of our
students when they come in or many many
of our students when they come in they
want to be forensic biologists and it's
because of CSI and so this article
basically wrote why is there not a you
know hacking coding equivalent of this
where a young woman can watch TV and see
another young woman coding and after we
some producers of MTV actually read this
article reached out to us saying that
they are producing a show where on MTV
where a young woman solves crimes using
computing and works for a sort of the
NYPD it's called eye candy and it's they
made the pilot and starring Victoria
Justice probably most developers don't
know who Victoria justice is but ask any
fifteen-year-old through her ear
justices and she'll freak out and I
didn't think invited me to teach the
entire cast out of code and so I was
sitting with Victoria justice and she
signs my robot getting a little weird
but you did and yeah it was just amazing
too and the director of Twilight
Catherine Hardwicke was there as well um
and so she's directing the show and that
was pretty unbelievable I couldn't
believe that my computer science degree
got me into the room with these amazing
creative people and was that it it was a
pretty cool moment my students were
obsessed late they thought it was the
coolest thing that's that's that's
awesome
I mean you you taught basically people
who probably had never thought they'd
learned how to code how to code and then
got a signed robot to boot yeah I mean
and they look the great thing about it
was they were awesome at it I mean they
were really good coders and I think that
speaks to the creativity piece yeah they
thought it was amazing and they loved
all the different applications they
could they could think about being used
on the show um because there's you know
naturally I could related back to my
work at MIT there's interesting crime
solving abilities inherent in computer
science that a lot of people don't know
about including the cast of the show
yeah definitely well that's fantastic
thank you so much Ashley for for joining
us today and telling us a bit about
girls who code we'll we'll see if we can
get some links to some resources that
you were mentioning today in the in the
description of the video so thank you so
much for joining us thanks for having me
was a lot of fun thank you for tuning in
to the special edition of women
techmakers
you can look forward to more segments
coming down the pipe to find out more
about girls who code visit girl code
and make sure to check out our previous
interview with Reshma so Johnny
founder of girls who code